while Leonard drawing valanciunas to his
shot at symbol au Tsubasa TV
Tippett Crowder flares out his three is
through on the Gruesomes have to leave
Garen for the deep catch of kick-out
extra pass Moran drives hangs on the
pitch out shot clock at 6 for Crowder
his three is through was nice with Dylan
to get shots to go down and here Marant
setting up Crowder flippers team is
going to win championship Sammy will be
big for them because they're gonna need
someone to knock down perimeter 300
contestants Terrans actually go to the
shot off of the glass their ankle sprain
here's Walton his three [ __ ] no and
the rebound to Valanciunas so Patrick
Beverley is out with the right wrist
sprain called Toriko job Marant thing is
he's already playing up and the thing
about these wing players and what's so
good but this grizzly team this year is
it always had to be Mike Conley to had
to bring the ball up every time look at
the catch dick first quarters have been
really good for the Grizzlies and
cheering good delivery by Crowder at his
hand in a little bit of everything in
that court Leonard takes middle against
gerund Jerry Jarrett stymied him and
then Leonard's out of our green in for
the first time mantras Darryl also has
come on Gerrans got an open look at a
three and he puts it in and the
Grizzlies six of eight from three to
smart this game art and finished here to
the second floor
Solomon Hill off the pump fake Iran with
a pump fake
Oh better hit down Oh whoopsie oh oh
Strohm robinson hand apple loser downing
just know I'm gonna say this way and
whoa whoa whoops whoops where'd he go
where'd he go let me compose myself and
then knock you down he had to come up
with it you had to compose himself earth
cuz after you make the move it's like
okay that did happen and he's not gonna
get back please
caramel on power forward of the Year
award the first time it was awarded
recent Allen he gets the three of the
Grizzlies already with 10 triples in the
game and the Grizzlies set it up up 10
brush screen Valanciunas the leaner is
in by Moran he's a double figures with
10 on the scout and see what the other
group was gonna look like from the
predator side so when we do it next time
I will rear a the bag tosses jaren
Jackson jr. is already always ready to
tee up with three apparel and heartless
Harkless through a forest of hands got
it to Harrell and he has it set back and
Jaron on the pick up 18 points in the
victory over Detroit on Thursday decided
to live it for him but he's knocked down
his last two Moran with a floater
the philosophies are Taylor Jenkins is
can we play position less basketball and
he's a guy who could certainly do that
John with a baseline move here's
Valanciunas and he is on the board for
the first time tonight the lead in the
leather here early third quarter Moran
oh what a pretty move a little bit of a
ball fake and then going baseline I'm a
rant but the thing about him never has
to touch the ball with his right hand so
he's NBA observer before the game and he
said what Dillon Brooks is doing now he
colors between the lines feather that he
did last year
competitive Allen Jun is a three-point
chance JV was 6 in a chance for 7 Moran
thought a step through a finger rolls it
up a knee and off the glass JAMA rant
you get one here moment 7 John Moran
with a pretty ball fake and the finger
roll off laughs one thing he could do
partners finger roll numerous
possessions within one with offensive
rebounds and take and make their shots
on there and as Moran is a big shot
maker and not having driven off from out
on the floor not in attack mode
good pass oh what a great find by Moran
and Jaron throws it down
rent the ball fake there something that
enough players do not use villain Brooks
comes away with it long lead jaren slams
it down off the set up by Dylan Brooks
and they have an opportunity at the
free-throw line here but you see the
nice throw it hit Jared doing a good job
of getting down the floor
Dylan eyes of Z's and much needed basket
with six remaining Lou Williams
wraparound good hands by Moretti
he's got the steal highly efficient
Jarrett's nice little stop on a dime got
my Harrell and laid it in and that's
only a flagrant fires player foul
they were clean but it would have been
just one free throw for Jaron here's
Dylan for three pango this is
back-to-back really good performances
and religious couldn't play a second and
fourth quarter as Jaron continues his
fourth quarter scoring yes you know I
think that there was a home court
advantage for the Predators because well
here's Jaron a deep three one at hand
right between the eyes and an
exclamation point from jaren Jackson
junior this is I'm coming out of the
game we see can I find one more shot
opportunity what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content